i love this one this is amazing it's
amazing it's like four stars somewhere i
already
have six stars just like in possibly oh
my god let's take a picture with you
right now okay here we go
oh my god i'm making a video one big
nose is deleted
oh my god what's my eye doing oh
[Applause]
[ __ ] your weapon
oh i totally look like cloverfield just
have a stroke or something
right yeah oh we're cute
ladies can you just show me the picture
you were talking about oh it's like
yeah stop great right there that's great
rick grady we got a clear shot of the
perpetrator he's holding his shotgun and
everything
like where'd the picture go we deleted
it what
i had childbirth face yeah it looked
like my grandmother having an orgasm
delete it grady book these idiots for
destroying evidence
ow ew why are you being so manhandling
elitist why are we even we were the
heroes of the evening
we stopped the perpetrator now we're
being arrested oh my god this carriage
of judges
oh what no oh god you cannot you cannot
arrest me with that picture are you
kidding me delete it
it's blinking this is ridiculous
[Music]
just got it deleted
you